ancienne député des Yvelines aujourd'hui
ministre des Solidarités et des familles
Aurore Berger a choisi la PMI le Centre
de Protection Maternelle et Infantile de
Rambouillet pour sa première visite
officielle dans le département elle a pu
rencontrer les professionnels du secteur
et échangés sur leur quotidien parce que
tu es intéressant c'est surtout
d'entendre les professionnels parler de
leur métier la manière avec laquelle ils
ont évolué tu fais qu'on est aussi
conscient que c'est peut-être plus
difficile d'être parents aujourd'hui ça
l'était il y a 20 ans ou 30 ans parce
qu'il y avait pas les mêmes risques on a
beaucoup parlé de la question des écrans
comment on fait pour expliquer aux
parents les risques évidemment qui
peuvent y être associés sans être
culpabilisant aussi pour les parents ou
enfantillisants mais on a besoin un
moment de prévenir de ces risques pour
faire en sorte que le développement de
l'enfance passe dans les meilleures
conditions possibles pourquoi mon bébé
pleure-t-il pourquoi est-Il constipé ou
encore quel aliment puis-je lui donner
autant de questions que les jeunes
parents peuvent se poser à la naissance
alors au sein du Centre de Protection
Maternelle Infantile de Rambouillet les
professionnel de santé sont à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos attentes
l'année dernière 700 enfants ont été
accompagnés à Rambouillet ainsi que 600
enfants grâce au bus itinérants les
difficultés qu'on rencontre au quotidien
sont aussi les difficultés que l'on peut
rencontrer avec des parents
l'éloignement des professionnels de
psychiatrie ou psychologues lorsque nous
avons des parents en difficulté on n'a
pas de chiffres exact mais effectivement
on constate de manière un petit peu
empirisme une augmentation du nombre de
mamans qui sont en difficulté
psychologique sur notre territoire et
d'ici 2030 la ministre souhaite
l'ouverture de 200 000 places d'accueil
de haute qualité